les sages ont donc finalement donné
raison au gouvernement le passe à
lithaire pourra être appliqué dès ce
lundi le projet de loi échappe à la
censure excepté pour une mesure du volet
travail est celle permettant un
employeur de rompre avant son terme un
contrat à durée déterminée ou un contrat
d'intérim en prévoyant que le défaut de
présentation d'un pass sanitaire
constitue une cause de rupture anticipée
des seuls contrats à durée déterminée ou
deux missions le législateur a institué
une différence de traitement entre les
salariés selon la nature de leur contrat
de travail qui est sans lien avec
l'objectif poursuivi cdd et cdi seront
donc logés à la même enseigne après
cette décision a pas de rupture de
contrat mais une suspension sans
rémunération quand certains s'en
réjouissent d'autres grincent des dents
en pratique les secteurs visés emploi le
plus souvent des cdd il est rassurant
que cette nouvelle rupture anticipée du
cdd est été censurés car elle était
particulièrement injuste et sanctionnait
les plus précaires très décevante
décision du conseil constitutionnel
ils ne protègent aucune des libertés
menacées par le passage ni terre humour
noir un cdd ne peut être interrompue
mais son salaire reste suspendue pour
préserver son salaire l'employé devra
donc présenter le résultat d'un test de
dépistage négatif un justificatif de
statut vaccinal ou alors un certificat
de rétablissement aux colis de 19 de
moins de 6 mois elle est sage observe
que la mesure de suspension du contrat
et temporaire puisque l'obligation du
pass année terre ne court que jusqu'au
15 novembre
si elle n'est pas plus tard prolongée de
nombreuses solutions s'offrent aux
employeurs et aux salariés autorisation
d'absence pour aller se faire vacciner
entretien entre l'employeur et le
salarié utilisation de jours de congés
ou de rtt affectations temporaires sur
un autre post recours au télétravail
suspension du contrat de travail le
temps que le salarié se conforme à ses
obligations
le conseil constitutionnel a validé
l'essentiel des dispositions de la loi
relative à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire elle permettra le plein
déploiement de notre stratégie de lutte
contre la copie 19 tel que présenté par
le président de la république le 12
juillet dernier et pour les salariés
réfractaires au pass sanitaires on parle
donc de suspension mais plus ouvertement
de licenciement elle et qu'elle ne
serait pas à exclure en croire
christophe noël avocat spécialisé en
droit du travail en principe le droit
comment autorise un employeur à
licencier un salarié dont le contrat est
suspendue trop longtemps ou si cela
cause un trouble caractérisé dans
l'entreprise mais il n'est pas certain
que l'on puisse licencier des salariés
sur ces motifs les décisions seront
disparates parce que la loi est mal
foutu parmi les salariés concernés par
l'obligation de présentation du pass
sanitaire figurent de nombreuses
professions exercées dans les bars
restaurants cafés cinémas musées salles
de sport parc d'attractions hôpitaux ou
encore dans les casernes de pompiers
dans la rue la contestation ne faiblit
pas des manifestations contre le passé
ni terre continue d'être organisées aux
quatre coins du pays